[Applause]
[Music]
happy tuesday everyone
so this is crazy on monday attorney
general merrick garland announced the
fbi would investigate a disturbing spike
in harassment intimidation and threats
of violence against school
administrators board members teachers
and staff a disturbing spike are we
talking about legitimate charges or trey
gowdy's hair
in the memo they decry threats of
violence but is it actual terroristic
activities or parents trying to get to
the bottom of a lousy education which in
the long run is more of a national
threat than china russia and iran
combined but the school board and the
law want you to think that parental
concern is now a domestic terror threat
that's right a mom yelling at school
board members at a public meeting is the
same as her donning an explosive vest
and blowing up a school demanding
quality schools is now like crashing a
plane into the pentagon
they've taken the most necessary debate
one could have how to teach your kids
and recast it as the perfect left-wing
fantasy heroic educators battling a mob
of pitchfork wielding heathens all
wearing mom jeans and fanny packs
and those are just the dads
garland published the memo right after
the national school board letter
demanded help from the white house
because our public schools and its
education leaders are under immediate
threat
first can you imagine asking joe biden
for help on anything
other than how to use metamucil
did you not see the kabul airport
evacuation
asking joe for help is like asking ted
bundy for a ride home
it was either that or ted kennedy i
couldn't make up my mind
that's not a good choice thank you now
there may be unsavory incidents but when
it comes to getting between a dad and
his kid who you've labeled racist
because of his race that can happen
teachers and parents will get into
shouting matches which isn't good but
it's understandable given the insane
teachers unions the brainwash they call
education the utter disregard for
difference of opinion they don't care if
our schools are dead last they only care
about preventing you from having a
choice of schools or a say in the matter
which could be why the nsba suggested
that these acts of malice could be the
equivalent to domestic terrorism
domestic terror is now more watered down
than cat's court-ordered urine sample
but the school board actually learned
something that if you claim something is
domestic terror it's in the eye of the
beholder and no one can tell you that
you weren't terrorized so you can use it
on anyone except of course rioters or
looters just angry parents and jess and
just you wait that harmless co-worker of
yours will be next
are you wearing body spray
yeah dog it's mountain glacier blast
ladies love it
hello department of homeland security
yes thank you
look it's three dollars in macy's and
cvs
[Applause]
all you have to do is weaponize the
potential for a threat and you can
silence anything through fear maybe i
can accuse my wife of being an immediate
threat when i'm trying to watch the game
and by game i mean the masked singer
think about it i don't watch games
parents parents were upset with mass
mandates being imposed on their kids not
to mention critical race theory in a
normal world that would be considered
both physical and mental abuse but this
is a joe biden world and it's considered
good instruction so rather than engage
the other side smeared the left hates
open debate almost as much as they love
open borders they hate legitimate
protests as much as they love riots and
now they have the law to intimidate you
into silence i wonder what the angry
white male has to say
[Music]
i was tired of being ignored by teachers
and school administrators that's why i
started homeschooling
don't forget to indent at the beginning
of a paragraph i know i know
now i can be ignored in the privacy of
my own home
i hope that's his kid
or someone should call the cops
i wonder what the angry black male has
to say
[Music]
all right back after this thanks for
listening to tyrus and tim
what gut failed can't you see i'm
working here
fine ask your question
what
the teachers union is referring to
parents as domestic terrorists
because they have a difference of
opinion
yeah that works that's a lot like me
trying to interview
hi um there's this man who asking me a
lot of questions i'm very concerned can
you make sure my kids are okay i'm
really concerned that they're not in
school right now please
so now the fbi will split their time
between tracking down men in viking hats
and
irate parents who were rude to teachers
as for the legitimate daily threats we
all get from al-qaeda we'll get to them
right after we raid the home of this
mouthy soccer mom had dawn and arrest
her in front of her kids because she had
her own thoughts about how her kids
should be educated so while they target
parents you can still follow a woman
into a bathroom and film her and the
president will defend it not only will
he defend it he'll probably ask what
kind of shampoo she uses
you can brutalize anyone or steal
anything in new york and be back on the
streets in hours you could torch
businesses and permanently ruin cities
like minneapolis and never see jail time
but the fbi needs to cuff a mom because
she raised her voice to a transitioning
social studies teacher with a rainbow
tattoo on her neck
yes antifa is just an idea but mom and
dad are deadly that's the world we live
in where your speech is redefined as
violence and their violence is redefined
as justice well done joe you really are
a unifier because we all think you're
nuts
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's so patriotic independence day
celebrates him veteran in florida gop
congressional candidate cory bell
acknowledges power her brain could blow
a fuse fox business correspondences and
lead
she's more demanding than a ransom note
fox news contributor cat tim
that sound you hear means he's doing
jumping jacks or there's a thunderstorm
approaching my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion tyrus
susan how are you i'm good how are you
i'm great i love the khakis
for halloween i'm going as tucker
carlson
i thought this is the tucker carlson
look that was good yeah yeah yeah i'm
not
you're gonna give me so much trouble you
know nobody sees me from the waist down
so i could get away with wearing the
khakis my wife wouldn't know now she
knows really we see you from the waist
down every day uh we have that cropped
out
speaking of cropped out i don't even
know where that means
um i don't know where this is going
i could actually say okay i could
actually paralyze this whole
conversation by saying you making uh
making a comment about my clothes kind
of threatens me right it's kind of a
threat to me because you're making me
prism i might be terrorism i think you
might have terrorized me susan okay yeah
you file a complaint with hr if you like
look i think it's it's crazy no no great
write him a scathing email
yeah it's too late you're done all right
but i just think it's great you're gonna
be on cnbc before you know it
i have no idea what that would be like
but i think it's crazy the school boards
have turned into an episode of squid
game which you should watch have you
watched you know what i'm talking about
yeah but you're you were saying it
correctly that there is a lot more
time to be spent say on fighting violent
crime for instance did you know that
murders went up 30 last year yeah 30
that is the most that we've seen since
1960. how about you know protecting
women that are being shoved in subways
exactly except for a cat
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding thank you that's the
sweetest thing you've ever said
corey you know what kills me is that all
the stuff that the media and democrats
were accusing trump of potentially doing
they're actually doing
this is something they're not even
trying to hide it no they're not hiding
it it's amazing they're paralyzed
they're actually going after law abiding
citizens so they get they're no longer
part of the dialogue 100 and look he
actually said this in the very beginning
he says look they're not after me
they're after you i'm just in the way
yeah and what is actually proving to be
true is is that now if you disagree with
anything that the us government says
they can just label you as a domestic
terror and utilize this blanket cover
and therefore the fbi just rushes in you
know here's what i would like to see you
know if they would have taken
half of that consideration into the
taliban haqqani network and everyone
else who was building themselves up in
afghanistan and focus their attention
there as a poster on our own american
citizens we'd probably in a lot better
position overall but instead they just
want to basically utilize the cancel
culture to extend itself out into
investigations and then arrest people
who just disagree with anything that
they have to say yeah
and they uh they completely like they
could have gone after maybe a olympic
gym coach who like you know raped and
molested all of these athletes all right
tyrus
um is it i mean
parents should have some modicum is that
he said monica of politeness when
talking to uh
teachers but
what i don't know i don't have kids no
you're supposed to cut me off when i
make no sense
oh i mean
[Laughter]
yellow socks and khakis you nailed it
bro
you know what as
what cracks me up is i was looking
online today try to find how many
buildings the parents burned down or
stores they robbed you know or people
they punched out or left dead bleeding
in the street and i can't really seem to
find a whole lot on these domestic
terrorists other than they all uniformly
go in a building wait their turn to get
in front of a microphone and then
complain until their time is up so
yes where are we living that that's a
dem
that word is used to mean something and
it was it was the last administration
literally anyone who said oh hey that's
president trump he was a domestic
terrorist so now they've because he's
not on twitter anymore they have turned
it on the people but they're leaving out
who's instigating this yeah who's
instigating who's the one making
comments like oh they're just mad
they're guy lost
oh they're who said that that was some
of the doj that was supposed to be
someone who was supposed to be helping
so the parents know that they're going
into a room with closed ears and closed
minds to begin with so forgive them if
they get upset over them fighting and
arguing over their most precious
commodity their children which used to
be our most precious commodity in this
country right and now it is if you don't
see the way we are there's something
wrong with you when this happened in the
60s it was the clan when this happened
you know before that it was jim crow and
before that it was the timber it always
seems to end up being the democrats they
think they know
what's best for you without ever
bothering to talk to you and that's and
that's a crime it's terrible that we're
going through that right now yeah it is
amazing it's also amazing that like they
need to coerce you into believing their
ideas
you can't do anything without us
especially you minorities but they mean
you you can't do nothing unless we want
try they're hijacking education i mean
the whole point is that they don't like
the fact that inundation of crt in our
education is being challenged yeah and
it's the whole point it's critical race
theory which means it's a critical idea
open for
discussion not critical race facts yeah
you know uh cat i think you know
theoretically with this definite this uh
i don't know categorization of terror
this show yes this show is an act of
domestic terrorism absolutely against
don lemon and brian williams because we
were just crushing them in the raid
[Applause]
well i was going to say like i don't
have kids
but if i did i would be yelling all the
time
i mean like i am already kind of on the
edge as it is yes and the good news is
like i
i get to be on a talk show where i say
how i feel right exactly they don't and
also it's just it's mind-blowing to
think about how truly truly insane it is
that you know these parents want to have
a say in their child's education they
want to have a say and where their kids
spend you know
you know a third of their day
for you know five days a week for nine
months out of the year for years of
their life at a location that their tax
dollars also pay for like that is not
only not terrorism that's about as
a good of an example of a basic
fundamental right as you can get yeah
well said thank you yes okay hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else